uno de los temas de la Cumbre es la
reactivación del unasur recordemos la
estructura creada en 2008 por los
gobiernos de izquierda de la región que
posteriormente se fue desintegrando a
medida que la derecha llegó a asumir el
poder en los países de América Latina le
pregunto qué objetivo tendría ahora
mismo revivir esta organización
gracias buenas tardes a todas y a todos
en primer lugar yo creo que es
importante reconocer que la zona Sur no
es necesariamente una creación de la
izquierda yo creo que unos más
importantes creadores de la unasur ha
sido el expresidente Uribe y donde
con justamente con Lula crearon un
espacio para el diálogo regional Incluso
el diálogo con Venezuela sin la
mediación de Estados Unidos Porque el
único otro espacio que existía era la
oea entonces tener un espacio regional
para que los gobiernos de Sudamérica
puedan pensar el futuro de la región Yo
creo que es fundamental ha sido
fundamental y realmente la falta de
compromiso de integración Regional de
una parte de los gobiernos que que
vinieron después
acabaron con la organización Yo creo que
el objetivo ahora es justamente de
pensar Cuáles son las ventajas de la
integración y la cooperación entre los
países por ejemplo el tema masónico que
interesa mucho en los países que tiene
una importancia geopolítica y
estratégica en el debate global el tema
de la reindustrialización posible en la
región con los cambios que se pasan en
Estados Unidos y en China o sea todos
esos temas tienes no pueden ser pensados
de forma aislada No Y ahí tener un
espacio de integración de de cooperación
entre los países es absolutamente
importante Entonces yo creo es muy
positivo que se vuelvan a hablar los
líderes en ese sentido Pero
concretamente le pregunto qué pasos se
pueden dar para que esta cooperación
esta integración no dependa de la
sintonía ideológica que tienen los
distintos países de la región
eso es fundamental y la presencia de
presidentes como
el presidente de Ecuador el presidente
de de Uruguay a presidente de Paraguay
que son presidente del campo conservador
en ese debate justo como juntamente con
presidentes que vienen en la izquierda
muestra que es absolutamente posible
Tener una convergencia programática
pensando en políticas públicas en unión
en comercio entre la región en
comparación tecnológica que no esté
vinculada a esa cuestión ideológica
Entonces yo creo que hay una visión
mucho que que la fue la el principio
ideológico que crió la unasur y por eso
se se después cuando cambian los
gobiernos
se acabó la la organización pero yo voy
a ser contrario se creó en un contexto
de diversidad ideología con Uribe y con
Lula por ejemplo en la región
y se destruyó a partir de una visión
ideológica de que la cooperación
mexicana es algo de la izquierda no
puede ser la integración suramericana
tiene que ser un proyecto de los estados
de la región independientemente de la
visión ideológica y yo creo que es eso
que transpareció en una reunión con
personas de de visiones y de y de
opiniones ideológicas tan distintas como
las que están en Brasilia ahora y le
quiero preguntar por algo que usted
apuntaba al principio y es la
importancia de gestionar digamos la
situación en Venezuela para la región
concretamente Qué significa la
asistencia de maduro a este encuentro en
Brasilia después de que no asistiera a
las últimas Cumbres o encuentros de todo
el continente americano o de la
organización iberoamericana de la celac
etcétera
creo que en políticas públicas y
internacionales también
hay que las apuestas tiene que ser
evaluadas la apuesta en el aislamiento
de Venezuela hace una apuesta que no
funcionó no generó no trajo mal
democracia ni más desarrollo económico
y ni bienestar al pueblo venezolano
Entonces yo creo que la la integración
de Venezuela para que se pueda construir
una salida a democrática para Venezuela
para que se puedan finalmente tener
elecciones libres en Venezuela es yo
creo una una estrategia mucho más
efectiva que tiene posibilidad real de
funcionar que el aislamiento que venció
Venezuela en los últimos años o en los
años anteriores Yo creo que es muy
positiva la presencia de Venezuela
porque abre la posibilidad de
negociación yo creo que trae una chance
más grande que se acerque democracia del
país